GREAT GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO THE FEBRUARY NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE BEFORE WE PROCEED
LET'S CALL THE ROLL AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. BERMAN HERE
BERMAN HERE SAY ARE TELL. FAIR
TOKYO BENNETT BENNETT HERE LOW
MAYES MULLIN RUBIO RUBIO HERE
WE HAVE A QUORUM GREAT THANK
YOU FOR EVERYBODY FOR SHOWING
UP ON TIME TO GET THIS STARTED
DUE TO THE CONTINUED STAY AT
HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THE MASKS BE WORN IN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING AS INDICATED IN THE
PUBLIC NOTICE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE COMMITTEE'S
LONGSTANDING RULES AND PRACTICE.
TESTIMONY IS BEING LIMITED
TODAY. THERE WILL BE A MAXIMUM
OFTWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. WITH A LIMIT OF
THREE MINUTES PER PRIMARY
WITNESS. THESE RULES GENERALLY
ARE CONSISTENT WITH HOW OTHER
POLICY COMMITTEES HAVE LIMITED
TESTIMONY AT HEARINGS ON BILLS.
THE DIFFERENT LIMITS MAY HAVE
BEEN USED IN BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND THAT
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS. THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES HAVE BEEN DOT
DESIGNATED IN ADVANCE AND ALL
IT ARE ALL CALLING IN. TO THE
HEARING TODAY THROUGH ARE
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR TODAY ARE ADVISED
THAT YOU WILL REMAIN ON THE
LINE PHONE LINE AND WILL NEED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. AFTER WE
HEAR FROM THE PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AND IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AND TODAY ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. WE WILL THEN
HEAR FROM ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF OR IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL WHO ARE CALLING IN
BY PHONE. OR WHO WERE HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM TODAY. THESE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY. IN THE
POSITION ON THE BILL. FOR THOSE
WHO ARE WATCHING THIS HEARING
REMOTELY. AND YOU WISH TO CALL
IN TO REGISTER THEIR POSITION.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR.
TWO OH TWO. AND THAT'S ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR. TWO OH
TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV OR COMPUTER SCREEN.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
PLAN TO DIAL IN IS THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON
IS BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN QUEUE. IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MOOT MEET MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART%
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2094 AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY
TO HELP. WE WILL ALSO HAVE THE
OPTION FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
HERE IN THE ROOM DIVERT PROVIDE
THEIR NAME THE ORGANIZATION
THAT THEY REPRESENT IF ANY IN
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL.
TODAY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR TWO
OF THE STATE CAPITOL WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF. AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THERE ARE
ALSO SURGICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOL OF THE PUBLIC TO ENTER
AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL. AND FOR
THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. WHEN WE
GET TO THE PORTION OF OUR
AGENDA FOR TESTIMONY BY THOSE
WHO ARE HERE IN THE ROOM. I
WILL ASK YOU TO RAISE YOUR HAND
AT THAT TIME AND I'LL ASK YOU
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE
DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT MATH IS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. 40% OF THE COMMITTEE'S
AGENDA. FIVE ONE ANNOUNCEMENT
TO MAKE. THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
REQUESTED. BY THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE TO PASS S. B. TWENTY
NINE DIRECTLY TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. SO THE MOTION ON THAT
BILL TODAY WILL BE TO PASS THE
BILL TO THE FLOOR. WITH ALL
THOSE MOMENTS OUT OF THE WAY WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA. THERE'S
JUST ONE BILL ON TE AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB TWENTY NINE
BY SENATOR UMBERG. IF THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CORE
MONITORING THIS HEARING
REMOTELY AND WHO ARE INTERESTED
IN SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF OR IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. PLEASE
CALL AND NOW. AS A REMINDER THE
PUBLIC CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH
TWO. SENATOR UMBERG THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK YOU UP
HERE BERMAN AND- MEMBERS. SB
TWENTY NINE REQUIRE ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO MAIL A VOTE. BY
MAIL BALLOT EVERY ACTIVE
REGISTERED VOTER- FOR SPECIAL
ELECTIONS HELD TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IT WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIALS. USE
THE VOTE BY MAIL TRACKING
SYSTEM THAT WILL ALLOW VOTERS
TO TRACK THEIR BALANCE. WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND I THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN. FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. ELECTION LAW OVER
THE COURSE LAST COUPLE YEARS I
VERY MUCH ENJOYED WORKING WITH
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
VERY TELL THE COMMITTEE STAFF-
I WANT TO CLARIFY. ONE THING.
ISTHAT THIS BILL. DOES NOT
OVERRIDE EXISTING LAW ON IN
PERSON VOTING. THAT WE WILL
STILL HAVE IN FACT IN PERSON
VOTING AS WELL AS VOTING Y
MAIL WITH PASSAGE OF S. B.
TWENTY NINE- THIS BILL SIMPLY
EXTEND THE PROTECTIONS PROVIDED
FOR THE NOVEMBER THREE TWENTY
TWENTY. ELECTION THROUGH AB.
EIGHT SIXTY YOU MAY RECOGNIZE
THAT BILL MISTER CHAIRMAN-
WHICH WAS SUCCESSFUL IN A
BIPARTISAN EFFORT WAS MADE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT VOTIG WAS SAFE
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR BOTH THE
WORKERS AS WELL AS THE VOTERS.
THE PANDEMIC HAS NOT GONE AWAY
AS IS EVIDENCED BY THE FACT
THAT WE'RE ALL. SO WE JUST AND
WE'RE MASKS THERE'S- WE NEED TO
EXTEND THOSE PROTECTIONS
AUTHORIZED MAYBE EIGHT SIXTY IN
ORDER TO GUARANTEE VOTERS AND
POLL WORKERS A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT. TO EMPOWER VOTERS
TO CHOOSE WHETHER FELT ABOUT
THAT HOME OR TO CAST THE VOTES
IN PERSON- THE ELECTION IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY WAS A
HUGE SUCCESS MORE THAN 80% OF
CALIFORNIA'S REGISTERED VOTERS
CAST BALLOTS IN NOVEMBER
ELECTION THAT WAS THE HIGHEST
TURNOUT SINCE HARRY TRUMAN WAS
PRESIDENT AND TO CLEAR UP THE
QUESTION BY MY STAFF I DID NOT
VOTE MY LECTURE. SO EXTENDING
THIS CRITICAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS FOR ADDITIONAL YEAR
WITH PANDEMIC STILL RAGING. IS
SIMPLY COMMONSENSE. A LOCAL
JURISDICTION HAVE USED ALL MAIL
ABOUT HER SPECIAL LECTURES TO
SAVE MONEY FOR SOME TIME. WITH
ME HERE TODAY OR X. EXCUSE ME
VIRTUALLY HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
AS ADULTS TAKE A LOWER THE
SECTOR THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. ELECTION
SITE LEAD AT THE ORANGE COUNTY
REGISTER OF VOTERS. AND I'VE
MISSED A TIFFANY MARC I THINK
IT'S ALSO ONLINE FROM SECTORS
BATES OFFICE THE ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I UNDERSTAND LIKE YOU JUST
MENTION THAT YOU'RE ONE PRIMARY
WILL DISCUSS TO FIND SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- SO ADULT TAKE A LOW
WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION PLEASE.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
EIGHT THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THANK YOU CHAIR BERMAN
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. AS MISTER
AMBERG. BURKE HAS STATED MY
NAME IS A DEL CONCA LOLA AND I
AM THE SECRETARY FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AS WELL AS AN ELECTRIFIED ME
ORANGE COUNTY REGISTRAR VOTERS.
LAST NOVEMBER FOR THE GENERAL
ELECTION I WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
HELPING ORANGE COUNTY IMPLEMENT
THE STATE REQUIREMENTS FOUND IN
SB FOUR TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR- BURKE. AND AB EIGHT
FEET BY FAMILY MEMBER BERMAN. I
AM HAPPY TO REPORT THAT ORANGE
COUNTY WITH THE ONLY. ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT. THOSE LAWS THAT
APPLY TO THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTIONS AND WE HAD AN
INCREDIBLE TURNOUT THAT 87% IN
ORANGE COUNTY. YOU TO COPE IN
NINETEEN. MY COWORKERS AND I
TRULY APPRECIATED THE
PROTECTIONS PUT IN PLACE FOR
THE EMPLOYEES. THAT WOULD HAVE
TO WORK AT THE FOLD AND BOTH
CENTER. ALL RIGHT ALL VOTERS
DURING THE ELECTION PERIOD.
FOLLOWING THE ELECTION- C. A.
HELD A MEETING WITH SENATOR
ALBERT WERE WE PROVIDED
FEEDBACK ON THE GUIDELINES AND
THE THINGS WE LIKED
OPERATIONALLY IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY NOVEMBER ELECTION. SO I
AM HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS BY SENATOR
ON BOARD AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP DEVELOP
THOSE RULES WE HAD IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOR THE SPECIAL ELECTION
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT IS
VERY CLEAR THAT COPING NINETEEN
IS STILL WITH US. BUT THAT
COULD NOT MEAN THAT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY. BOB REGARDLESS OF
THEIR AGE AND ABILITIES AND ALL
WORKERS NEED TO BE PUT AT RISK
WHEN WE HAVE AN ELECTION. THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GREAT DAY. THANK YOU MISS
TUGGLE LAW- AND I UNDERSTAND WE
ALSO HAVE TIFFANY MOCK WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE ON THE LINE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MS MOCK WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS OR
RESERVE FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
ALREADY FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE A
MOTION. AND A SECOND. YES I WAS
A MARK YEAH GOOD TO GO THANKS-
SO THAT COMPLETES OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWENTY NINE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE
HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION THOSE
WITNESSES REPRESENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SUBMITTED
LETTERS TO THE COMMITTEE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWENTY NINE.
THE FIRST WITNESSES SCOTT
KAUFMAN WITH THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WHO IS ON
THE PHONE MISTER KAUFMAN YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES. ALL RIGHT
WELL ACTUALLY IF I COULD MAKE A
SUGGESTION IF THE OTHER SPEAKER
IS- THE ELECTION INTEGRITY.
PROJECT THEIR PROGRESS SAID-
BETTER ON THE TECHNICAL SIDE
PERHAPS THEY CAN GO FIRST AND I
WILL JUST. FILL IN THE BLANKS
AT THE END I THINK- WE COULD
SAVE YOU SOME TIME THAT WAY IF
THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU THAT
THAT WORKS JUST FINE FOR ME-
THE SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS WHO
WILL NOT BE THE FIRST PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IS RUTH WEISS. OF ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA
WHO WAS ON THE PHONE. MS WEISS
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF ACCOLADES COMING FROM
THE LEGISLATURE IN STATE LIKE
THAT. AT THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION AND THERE'S
GREAT START BEING PUT IN HAVING
ACHIEVED THE HIGHEST VOTER
TURNOUT RATE AND HISTORY ONE
CREDITING THE PRECIPITOUS AND
LAST MINUTE CHANGES IN ELECTION
PROCEDURES FOR THAT FACT. ON
VIDEO THE DECEPTIVE AND
DISINGENUOUS RETURNING AND NOW
ON A STATISTICIAN WOULD DRAW
THAT CONCLUSION. THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION WAS ONE OF THE MOST
CONTENTIOUS HIGH ENERGY AND
HIGH STAKES CONTEST THIS
COUNTRY'S EVER SEEN THAT'S WHAT
DROVE THE HIGH TURNOUT
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS WILL TELL
YOU IT'S MEANINGLESS IF THEY
TURN OUT WITHOUT THAT COMPARED
TO ANY OTHER ELECTIONS AND A
SQUAD THAT INCREASED ANYTHING
OTHER THAN VOTER. INTEREST SO
STANDING OUT ON REQUESTED
BALLOTS ALL REGISTERED VOTERS
MOST LIKELY NOT BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASE IN THE TURNOUT OF
LEADS BUT THE OF LEGITIMATE
VOTERS BUT HE DID GREATLY
INCREASE. THE PROBABILITY THAT
ILLEGITIMATE VOTES WERE CAST
AND COUNTED. YEAH IF YOU SEE A
SENT A LETTER TO CALIFORNIA'S
SECRETARY OF SECRETARY STATE
INTERVIEW APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
WHAT THE REPORT SHOWING OVER
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND LIKELY BETTER
RELOCATED PERSON. WOULD BE
MAILED BALLOTS AND TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND WOULD BE MAILED TO OUR
MORTALITY IF ALTHOUGH ALL
VOTERS WERE SENT A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS AND NO ACTION WAS TAKEN
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING AND
THE RESULT CREATED AN ELECTION
INTEGRITY CRISIS. WHICH IS
GREATLY EXACERBATED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. LAST MINUTE
EMERGENCY RIGHT. ARKAN ABOUT.
THOSE IT MAKE RATED ANY
MEANINGFUL THING VERY. AND
ALLOWED PER UNTOLD NUMBERS TO
ELIJAH CAL OUT THE FLIPPED THE
FIFTH. AND NEED SOME FROM OFF.
IN THE BUDGET- PERHAPS NUMBER.
CHAMPASSAK MANTRA THAT THE
ELECTION BE EXPECTS AND PAT
OFFICIALS ON THE DOESN'T MAKE
IT TRUE. VOTERS ABOUT TO OUR
VALID BETTER INFO GOT YELLED AT.
IT MOTOR TO GOT BACK. EAST ONES
FOR FORMER RESIDENTS OF THEIR
CAR. YOUR DOCTOR TOLD LONG THE
OTHER OR FORCED. AND NONCITIZEN
YOU GOT BALLOT THAT THEY NEVER.
TO RECEIVE NO. FROM THE- OF
ELECTRIC AND YOUR YOU. NO
TWENTY TWENTY WITH BUT A FIX
THAT KEEPING BLINDERS WILL ALL
pMAKE THIS. WORSE THIS NEEDS TO
TAKE X. MEASURES TO REGAIN THE
TRUST OF ITS PEOPLE NOT DOWN ON
HIS. IDEAS THIS IS OPENING UP
VACCINES ARE JUST P. EVERY
THEIR- AND WE KNOW HOW TO DEAL
WHATEVER A MERGER PER. AND
VOTER KNOW HOW ASK FOR A MAY
ABOUT THING ONE DON'T REPEAT
THE MISTAKES OF TWENTY TWENTY
AND MAIL HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS
OR HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS. OF ON
REQUESTED BALLOTS TO REGISTERED
UP QUESTIONABLE EXISTENCE OR
LEGITIMACY INSTEAD RETURN YOUR
VET RECORD TENSIONS AND
MANDATING LEGITIMATE VOTER ROLL
MAINTENANCE. AND REGAINING THE
FAITH AND TRUST THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING PUBLIC I URGE YOU TO
RETHINK AND REJECT SB TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PERFECT TIMING MS WEISS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NOW WILL MOVE ON
TO MISTER KAUFMAN. IN AN EFFORT
I CAN GIVE YOU MY FOR AND I
THINK THE- ON. SO ALL THE
TECHNICAL. OF HAVE BEEN OF
WORKING THOUGHT IT KIND OF MY
BULLET POINTS- IT'S IS
IMPORTANT THE PUBLIC HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN OUR ELECTION THAT
AT EVERY LEVEL FROM STATEWIDE
OFFICES LOCAL TAX MEASURES
THAT'S ESPECIALLY LIKE THE
HARDER TECH VERIFICATION
CONCERN- IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN U.
S. SUPREME COURT HELD IN IN
OHIO CASE HUSTED V. A. PHILIP
RANDOLPH INSTITUTE THAT IS
MANDATORY FOR STATES REMOVE
INACTIVE VOTERS. FROM THE VOTER
ROLLS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AGREED IN A
TWENTY NINETEEN SETTLEMENT OF A
LAWSUIT. OVER AN ACTIVE VOTER
REGISTRATIONS REMOVE THEM AND
REPORT THEM ANNUALLY UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A FEDERAL JUDGE
ON THE ACTIONS TAKEN TO
MAINTAIN CURRENT ACCURATE VOTER
ROLLS IN ACCORDANCE WITH THIS
FEDERAL LAW. ONE OF THE GROUP'S
INVOLVEMENT SETTLEMENT AND WHO
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM TODAY
THE ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA NOTIFIED SECRETARY
STATE PARTY IN OCTOBER. THAT
THEY BELIEVE NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND BALLOTS
WERE MAILED TO PEOPLE WILL
LIKELY MOVED OR DIED IN TWO IN
TWO TO FOUR BALLOTS WERE MAILED
TO EACH OTHER TWENTY THOUSAND
VOTERS. TO ASSIST IN COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL LAW INTO ASSURE
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS THE
NEW BALLOT TRACKING SYSTEM
WHICH HAS BEEN MADE AVAILABLE
TO VOTERS THAT WHERE'S MY ABOUT
DOT COM DOT. DOT C. O. S. DOT
CA DOT GOV. SHOULD BE USED BY
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
GENERATE PUBLIC REPORTS FOR
EACH COUNTY OF THE NUMBER OF
BALLOTS MAILED OUT RETURN. FUND
RETURNED UNDELIVERABLE RETURN
COMPLETED COUNTED AND NOT
COUNTED FOR REASONS NOTED AND
WE THINK THAT SB TWENTY NINE
SHOULD BE AMENDED. TO REFLECT
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER COUGH. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITION
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWENTY NINE.
AS A REMINDER THESE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME. THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
REPRESENT IF ANY. IN THE
POSITION ON THE BILL. WE WILL
FIRST OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. WHO
WISH TO PROVIDE THEIR POSITION
ON SB TWENTY NINE. THE PHONE
LINES ARE NOW OPEN. I BELIEVE
WE HAVE MORE THAN SIXTY PEOPLE
ON THE LINE. MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK EITHER IN
SUPPORT OF OR IN OPPOSITION. TO
S. B. TWENTY NINE. EIGHT BERMAN
WHO DO WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONE ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE QUITE A FEW CLEAN UP WOULD
JUST BE A MOMENT. OUR FIRST
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL COME FROM
THE LINE OF NINE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. COUNTY TO GO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. UP NEXT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE LINE OF ONE OF
THESE BY HEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE AWAITS. HELLO HI YES WE. HI
MY AND COMMITTEE YES IF YOU
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL AND
ANY ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
IF YOU REPRESENT ANY. SO YOU
CAN HEAR ME IN IN IN ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE AT MY ON THE LINE YOU
ARE ON THE NEW TECHNOLOGY TO ME
YES YOU ARE ON THE LINE THIS IS
YOUR BERMAN ELECTION COMMITTEE
WE CAN ALL HEAR YOU- WELL. THE
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT THAT
YOU LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE WHO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO POINT
REPRESENTED WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SEE THE POSITION ON THE BILL.
IT IS BUT IN THIS STATE MY NAME
IS AND THE BEST TO GET THEM
BACK AND- MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
BIGGER. IN ONE MOMENT.
WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE NEXT A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO THE OPERATOR IS GONNA GIVE
YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER AND YOU'LL
BE ANNOUNCED BY YOUR LIFE.
THANK YOU OPERATOR. OUR NEXT
WILL COMPETE ONLINE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS SUSAN
KENNEDY SAN DIEGO COUNTY
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE SB
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FIFTY ZERO THIRTY
EIGHT YES SIR WE DID WE CAN.
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME POSITION
ON THE BILL IN ANY ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE. MY NAME
IS RICHARD ARM POSITION ON THE
BILL IS THAT I'M OPPOSED TO-
ALL. UP THERE WAS TWO OF BAIL
OUT TO EVERYBODY- THERE'S JUST
TOO MUCH ROOM FOR FRAUD THANK
YOU. JUST YOURS IS ON THE BILL.
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
THANK YOU. OKAY OPERATOR TO
MOVE TO THE NEXT. MOMENT PLEASE.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE OH TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT NINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THANK
YOU MY NAME IS ROBIN CUTS AND I
AM REPRESENTING OUR PROTECTING
MY OWN PERSONAL RIGHT AND MY-
RESPONSE IS NO TO THIS I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- CAN
VALIDATE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT JUST I. REMIND EVERYBODY
PLEASE JUST PROVIDE YOUR NAME.
IF YOU'RE REPRESENTING IN OR
PART OF AN ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION OF SUPPORT OR
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
ONE MOMENT TO THE NEXT
QUESTION. OR COMMENT SKEWS ME.
NEXT OVER THE LINE SEVENTY SIX.
AND SEVENTY AROUND IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I AM
CALLING REPRESENTING MYSELF
FROM POSTURE AND I OPPOSE SB
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OUR NEXT WILL BE LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS MARYLAND PAYMENT AND I
OPPOSE SB TWENTY NINE. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. EXTRA GOING TO LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD MY NAME IS MARY
THREE I LIVE IN SANTA CLARITA
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND AYE
OPPOSED SB TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO THE LINE ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS WAYNE CURVA
COLLECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
SENATE BILL TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO GO ON THE LINE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS DIANE SUTTON
FROM VENTURA COUNTY CALIFORNIA
A MEMBER OF ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO S. B.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO.
IF YOU VOTE YES ON THE FRONT
CERTIFICATION BILL THERE WILL
BE HUGE CAMP PLEASE W. OUT OF
BOX PROVIDING. ALL RIGHT- AND
INTEGRITY. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MAUREEN
CRIED I'M A REGISTERED VOTER
AND ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE. S. B.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I THAT SAYS THAT LARA
FINANCED CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR
POINT POINT. I WOULD ASK TWO B.
NINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN SO I HAD.
HI YES MY NAME IS THERE SHALL
AND I REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND YOU GUYS IF YOU
PRACTICE THESE PROVIDE YOUR
NAME OSITION ON THE BILL AND
THEY WERE GOING TO SEE MY
REPRESENT. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE.
NINETY TWO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LINE
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS I AM HERE. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. YOU CAN HEAR ME
OKAY EXCELLENT MY NAME IS
LIBERTY I REPRESENT THAT COUNTY.
AND IF NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
ALLOWED ON IN PERSON BOTH. DAN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SHOULD DO THE
SAME I AM OPPOSED TO SB TWENTY
NINE STRONG WAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS SHANNON I AM FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I AM
EXTREMELY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
OF MAIL IN BALLOTS THE
INTEGRITY OF LOSS IN THE
COLLECTION AREA MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR THIS BILL HAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE TWENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANKS
FOR VISITING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE BOTTOM
LNE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ROBERT
WHITE- NUMBER PPOSED TO IT S.
B. TWENTY NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
IS SEVENTY ONE GO AHEAD. YES
JULIA FRIEDMAN NINE TWO ONE
ZERO NINE I REPRESENTS THE VETS
WHO WITNESSED ALL THE FLAG
SIGNATURES AT THE R. O. B.
HEARING TEN YEARS AGO OPPOSED
TO TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE FOURTEENS PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAROL HAVE MAC FROM SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
S. B. TWENTY NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO LINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CANELO SON SANTA
CLARA COUNTY HI- LOCALS TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE AT NINETY
THREE THIS BILL HEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS KAREN BILL
SKI I'M A REGISTERED VOTER IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY- I OPPOSE
S. B. TWENTY NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE OF ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DAVID SCHECHTER
REGISTERED VOTER VENTURA COUNTY
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU. WELL
I DON'T ONE NINE NINE IS GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS JENNIFER MALLEY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND WE ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE OH ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME'S ELIZABETH
WARREN. LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
I OPPOSE SB TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE LINE ONE OH
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
KATHERINE COREY A REGISTERED
VOTER IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE SB TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING MY NAME IS VERONICA
SHOT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
NINE- TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE THIRTY THREE IS GO AHEAD
SORRY YEAH. WE GOT TO THANKS MY
NAME IS GLORIA MATHIS SHOULD
NOW. AND I'M A REGISTERED VOTER
IN VENTURA COUNTY I THANK
CHRONIQUE PUBLIC SB TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE ONE FORTY TWO IS
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS AMY
HAMBLIN WITH NEXT GEN POLICY
CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'VE BEEN ON THE LINE
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS WENT
DEEPER QUINCY ON WITH THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY- COORDINATOR FOR
THE ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
OF CALIFORNIA AND I STAND
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO S. B.
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY NINE
THIS GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH MY NAME IS DEBORAH DELEE
AM MY REGISTERED BORDER AN
ORANGE COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB TWENTY. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
PHYLLIS NAME IF I'M A
REGISTERED VOTER IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO SB TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE
ZERO THREE ONE THREE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS CASEY HENSLEY FROM
STAMINA DINO COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE S. B. TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
ERICA ETCETERA FROM SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AND MY OLD BOSS SB
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY NINE
IS GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI JANUARY FROM THE STATE WIDE
GRIP THE JUDEO CHRISTIAN CAUCUS
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK. NEXT OVER THE
LINE EIGHTY ONE IS GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
KEN SCOTT I'M CALLING FROM
PLASTER COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWENTY NINE THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN IS GO AHEAD.
FIRE REGISTERED VOTER THE I. P.
R. CONSTITUENTS BUYOUT STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWENTY NINE THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MARISSA CARTER I'M CALLING
IN OPPOSITION SB TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT IS
LINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
NANCY RADER RIVERSIDE COUNTY
INDIVIDUAL OPPOSED THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEATHER BENNETT'S KERN
COUNTY REGISTERED VOTERS
OPPOSED TO ESTATE TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CAROLINE
OVER TONGA REGISTERED VOTERS
SAN MATEO COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TWENTY NINE. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
AT NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
SHARON HELL UNREGISTERED VOTERS
L. A. COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN IS BY HEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS THE LATEST
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY A-
REGISTERED VOTER AND I AM
REQUESTING A VOTE FOR NO BOND
SB TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADELINE
COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE URGENCY AND
VOICE SUPPORT FOR SB TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS TONY SCHANTZ
INDIGO COUNTY OR REGISTERED
VOTER I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
AB TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR GOING TO LINE ONE OH
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ROBIN
MCVEIGH I'M A REGISTERED VOTER
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHEN MEMBERS AARON RODRIGUEZ
FOR THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT MOSBACHER
I AM A PERMANENT ABSENTEE VOTE
BY MAIL VOTER AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB TWENTY NINE
THANKS. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM VERY OLD
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND I AM
OPPOSED TO BE TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FIFTY IS GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WHEN THEY GO
ORANGE COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED
THIS FRAUD INDUCING
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. NEXT
GOING TO LINE ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ONE FIFTY
THREE YES. WELL. MY NAME IS
ANDREA HEDSTROM I AM A
REGISTERED VOTER IN SACRAMENTO
KIANI AND YOU CAN TELL BY THE
NUMBER OF CALLS WHAT THE PEACE
THROUGHOUT YOUR NAME OR
POSITION ON THE BATTLE AND ANY
ARISING YOU. IN THIS ALLEGED
FOR. AND THAT THE- ARE PLEASE
THE NEW. HELLO OUR NEXT LOVE BE
LINE FIVE IS THE AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT. SEVENTY FIVE. YEAH
SEVENTY FIVE ONE MOMENT NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JOHN CARNEY I'M A REGISTERED
VOTER IN CARD CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU.
THAT'S WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS A DOCTOR DOES OPENS
AND WOOD COUNTY SCRIPTS-
COMMITTEE ORGANIZER AND- ASKED
WE OPPOSE WE STRONGLY OPPOSE-
THIS- THIS LEGISLATION THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY IS GO AHEAD. I AM THE
ONE SEVENTY. NUMBER ONE FORTY
ONE THIS IS YEAH YOU'RE ON. HI
MY NAME IS ANNETTE BILL ON FROM
MARK. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED.
PUBLISHING I A MEMBER OF
ELECTING. THANKS YOU HAVE WITH
AT HER IRAQI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENSEN
HUANG AND I AM- BROWN SHOULD
THE KALAK COUNTY ELECTION
INTEGRITY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. BUT NEXT ONE
LINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS NANCY
WHEELER I REPRESENT THE STATE
WIDE LEGISLATIVE CALL THE GROUP
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU. YEAH
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ADAM RIGHT FROM ORANGE COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE ONE NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
ROBIN ELLIS AND I REPRESENT A
STATE WIDE LEGISLATIVE GROUP
CALLED CALLED THE GROUP AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE ONE AT NINETY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IS AN HOSKINS ORANGE
COUNTY MISSION VIEJO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO LINE ONE NINETY NINE IS THE
HEAD. HI MY NAME IS THAT IT I'M
AND I JUST SORT OF WATER AND I
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE WHO DONT
WANT COMMUNISM IN THIS COUNTRY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT THE LOW LINE. YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MOBILE
MOVEON WILL LAST FOUR FIFTY THE
NEXUS LINE TWO ZERO THREE. WHO-
THREE ONE MOMENT. OKAY TWO OR
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THERE IS NO RESPONSE.
WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT'S IN Q.
THAT'S GOOD IN THEIR LINE
NUMBER. ONE MOMENT. LINE MOST
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS A JAMES
RYAN CALLING FROM SANTA CLARA
COUNTY CALLING IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
Q. FOR COMMENT. OKAY. GIVE ME
ONE SECOND. WE'LL MOVE ON-
THANK YOU WELL WILL NOW MOVE ON
ANYONE WHO IS HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
PROVIDE THEIR POSITION ON SB
TWENTY NINE IF SO PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND. AS A REMINDER IT-
EITHER WAS IT DOESN'T MATTER NO
ONE'S HERE ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY SHARES HERE TO. THANK YOU
POSTERS MISTER CHAIR MY SPEAKER
ON YEAH. THERE WE GO PERFECT.
ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU SENATOR
AMBER FOR- PRESENTING THIS BILL
THIS MORNING AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONCERNS OVER OUR HEALTH
AND SAFETY DURING THIS PAST
PANDEMIC AND- IT'S A
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED
LAST YEAR ADDRESSED- YEAH- WITH
THE INFORMATION WE HAD HOWEVER
THIS YEAR IS A NEW YEAR WE'VE
LEARNED TO DEAL WITH SOME OF
THESE ISSUES- OF SAFETY. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
NOTICED IN THE LAST ELECTION
WAS THE- CENTRALIZATION OF
POLLING PLACES FOR PEOPLE THAT
HAVE DISTRUSTED IN THE SYSTEM
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF THOSE-
CAUSED VOTING DAY LINES AT
SECTOR- THAT EXACERBATED THE
ISSUE OF PEOPLE BEING EXPOSED
MORE EXPOSED TO EACH OTHER.
INSTEAD OF MAINTAINING THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAD WHERE WE HAD
MORE OF A DECENTRALIZED VOTING
SYSTEM. SO THAT IS A CONCERN MY
OTHER CONCERN IS THIS. WE HAVE.
A LOT OF DISTRUST NOW IN OUR
VOTING SYSTEMS. AND. TWO
THOUSAND ONE THERE IS A
COMMISSION AND IT WAS- THE
PUBLIC TO OF THE CHAIRS WERE
GERALD FORD AND JIMMY CARTER
BOTH PRESIDENTS- AND ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE WAS THIS A DAY WERE
SPECIFICALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
VOTER BY MAIL AND THE POTENTIAL
FOR PEOPLE TO ABUSE THAT- AND
ORGANIZATIONS TO ABUSE THAT
PROCESS AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF-
YEAH LIKE THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
CASES INVOLVING NURSING HOMES
WHERE PEOPLE WENT IN AND DID
YOU KNOW- HARVESTED BALLOTS OUT
OF NURSING HOMES WITHOUT REALLY
THE KNOWLEDGE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
FOR US TO HAVE TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON THAT AND CONTINUE DOWN THE
PATH OF FURTHER ALIENATING. A
LOT OF PEOPLE AND CREATNG MORE
DISTRUST WITHOUT ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE ISSUES OF THE
BALLOT INTEGRITY. IT'S HARD FOR
ME TO SUPPORT- THIS BILL- SO-
WITHOUT A LOT OF AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD HELP ALLEVIATE THOSE
CONCERNS. AND REGAIN THE TRUST
OF THE PUBLIC WHICH IS
SOMETHING WE DESPERATELY HAVE
TO DO IN THE STATE- IT I WON'T
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL SO
I DO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
TO US. MISTER BENNETT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE STRUCTURE
I WOULD LIKE TO COMPLEMENT THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND- I THINK WE'VE
HEARD- THROUGHOUT THIS COUNTRY
OVER AND OVER AGAIN CONCERNS OF
THE SENSUALLY- THE WHOLE ISSUE
OF DEMOCRACY IN THIS COUNTRY
HAS HAS BEEN IN FRONT OF US AND
ON THE BALLOT- AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE I THINK IT'S JUST
ANOTHER. EXAMPLE OF TRYING TO
HELP VOTERS TO BE ABLE TO- IN
GAUGE IN THAT- RIGHT TO VOTING
THAT THEY HAVE SO- WE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN HAVE HEARD
COMPLAINTS ABOUT POTENTIAL
FRAUD AND YET WEEKS WE SHOULD
HAVE CONSTANTLY WE DON'T SEE
ANY SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF
FRAUD OUT THERE- AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT'S- THE TICKET. HACK
INTO TO TALK ABOUT THIS IS IF
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT FRAUD ISSUE
WITHOUT THAT EVIDENCE- DOESN'T
DO US ANY FAVORS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR FOR BRINGING US
FOR. THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT
IS RUBIO. THANK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU- FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PARTICIPATE I
WANTED TO SAY A FEW WORDS ON
HOW GRATEFUL I AM TO STAND IN
THE LEGACY OF FORMER ASSEMBLY
WOMAN NOW SECRETARY OF STATE DR
SHIRLEY WEBER AND I KNOW THAT
HER WORK IN THE SERVING THAT
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED AND SOUL
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND I. UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS HOWEVER I CAN TELL YOU
FROM MY COMMUNITIES THE
EXCITEMENT FROM FROM VOTERS I
HAD NEVER VOTED BEFORE AND HOW.
GOOD THEY FELT TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE AND WE SAW THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE OF OUR VOTER TURNOUT
NOT JUST IN THE STATE IN THE
COUNTRY BY SPECIFICALLY MY
DISTRICT AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU
THAT THOSE FOLKS HAD FELT
DISENFRANCHISED BECAUSE THE IT
WASN'T EASY FOR THEM TO-
PARTICIPATE IN OUR SYSTEM BUT
THIS WILL HELP. AND I THINK- RE
ENGAGE AND ENGAGE NEW VOTERS I
THANK YOU FOR- THE YOU KNOW
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND AGAIN
I HOPE THAT THOSE ISSUES OF
DISTRUST- ARE FIXED BUT A LOT
OF TIMES THAT THIS TRUST IS
BASED ON- RHETORIC AND IF WE
CAN FIND A REAL. ISSUES TO
ADDRESS THEM I THINK WE SHOULD
DO SO HOWEVER IF WE'RE BASING
THAT DISTRUST ON RHETORIC THAT
I THINK WE NEED TO REALLY LOOK
AT THE ADVANTAGES. OF THE YOU
KNOW THE- BEING ABLE TO VOTE-
BY MAIL AND AGAIN THAT THE PART
TO SIT. THAT HAS INCREASED
BECAUSE OF ITS SIZE THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I SHOULD
SAY WELCOME TO THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO IS A MEMBER BENNETT
ADVICE OR C. R. GO WE'RE WE'RE
EXCITED TO HAVE. ALL THREE OF
YOU- MISTER MAYES. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND OTHERS
QUESTIONED- EITHER FOR OF THE
AUTHOR OR HE WOULD EVEN INVITE
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT TO.
THE TO CHIME IN AS WELL- OTHER
STATES- IN IN THE COUNTRY THAT
HAVE ALL MAIL BALLOTS- THANK
YOU SOME OF MY ROOMMATES YET
YES I BELIEVE THERE ARE FIVE
THAT HAD ALL BILL IN ELECTIONS
PRIOR TO. TWENTY TWENTY. AND IN
THOSE STATES- IS THERE
WIDESPREAD FRAUD IN THOSE IN
THOSE STATES. WELL I WOULD
SUSPECT NOT OF YOUR SO FOR
EXAMPLE STATE OF UTAH- WHICH IS
HAD MAIL IN ALL MAIL ELECTIONS
FOR SOME TIME HAS
OVERWHELMINGLY REPUBLICAN.
REPRESENTATION SO MY GUESS IS
THAT THEY'VE NOT EXPERIENCED
WIDESPREAD FRAUD. ARE THERE ANY
PROVISIONS IN THOSE STATES THAT
ALLOW FOR ALL MAIL BALLOTS
THAT- THAT THEY HAVE A THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD LOOK AT TO MAKE
SURE TO REDUCE FRAUD IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT I THINK WE'VE
INCORPORATED- SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY SO FOR EXAMPLE- ONE OF
BALLOTS IS. MAILED THERE'S A
BAR CODE ON THE BALLOT COMES
BACK THAT BARCODE IS CHECKED
AGAINST THE ORIGINAL BARCODE
THERE WAS MAIL WHICH IS ALSO
CHECKED AGAINST THE SIGNATURE.
YOU HAVE TO BE A REGISTERED
VOTER IN ORDER TO GET A MAIL IN
BALLOT SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE
PROVIDED YOUR SIGNATURE TO THE
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS AT SOME
POINT IN TIME IN THOSE
SIGNATURES ARE CROSS CHECKED
AND INDEED SOMETIMES- IF THE
SIGNATURES DON'T MATCH OF THE
SIGNATURES. ARE QUESTIONABLE
THAT BALLOT IS NOT COUNTED.
GREAT THEY YOU TO CHER IS THAT
NOTHING QUESTIONS JUST REAL
QUICK COMMENT- I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THIS AT TODAY. I
KNOW THIS IS A TEMPORARY
PROVISION TO GO TELL- UP UNTIL
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TO
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION- THAT WOULD- UP
PROVIDE FOR- CALIFORNIA TO BE
AN ALL MAIL BALLOT. I'M STATE-
I MADE STRONG SUPPORTER OF THAT
I HAVE BEEN SINCE I FIRST
BECAME A PERMANENT ABSENTEE
VOTER. I THINK THAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN- TWENTY YEARS AGO- OUR
GOAL AS A LEGISLATURE A NEEDS
TO BE TO BE ABLE TO TRY TO GET
AS AS MUCH. I MAKE IT AS EASY
AS POSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE
MAKE SURE THAT- THERE PROPERLY
PROPER REGISTERED VOTERS AND
THAT THEY'RE ALLOWED TO BE ABLE
TO VOTE THAT THEIR LEGAL VOTES
THAT ARE CAST BUT LET'S MAKE IT
EASIER FOR PEOPLE. TO BE ABLE
TO VOTE SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MAYES MR LOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. CHAIR CENTER NUMBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING- THIS MEASURE FORD-
IT'S A CONTINUATION OF THE- A
PARTNERSHIP NOT ONLY. IN THE-
ESSENCE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO THE WORK OF
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
CHAIRMAN BERMAN AS WELL. AND
APPRECIATE THE TWO HOUSES
WORKING TOGETHER. TO THE
BENEFIT OF. THE RECOGNITION
THAT. THEY COULD THIS COMMITTEE
MAKE UP AS DOWN NOW CHANGED.
I'VE SERVED AS A LEGISLATIVE
STAFFER FOR THE FORMER CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PAUL FONG. AS WELL AS SERVING
AS FORMER CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE. AS WELL AS BEING A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME. AND I JUST HAVE
TO SPEAK OUT. ON THE ON THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE ELECTIONS
INTEGRITY PROJECT BECAUSE-
WE'D- IT IS SO OFFENSIVE IT
MUST NOT GO WITHOUT BEING
CHALLENGED AND JUST FOR MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE TO BE. WELL
AWARE OF WHAT THE ELECTIONS
INTEGRITY PROJECT IS.
REGISTERED WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE. ELECTIONS INTEGRITY
PROJECT A WYOMING CORPORATION.
AUTHORIZED TO DO BUSINESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
DAY COMMENTARY FROM THEY
REPRESENTED FROM THE ELECTIONS
INTEGRITY PROJECTS SAID THAT
THIS WAS THE VOTING. THE VOTING
SYSTEMS AND THE TURNOUT WAS A
DISASTER AND THAT IS COMPLETELY
COUNTER TO THE FUNDAMENTAL.
LANGUAGE THAT OF ELECTIONS
INTEGRITY AND THAT WE HAVE
ELECTIONS INTEGRITY. AND
FORTUNE I'VE HEARD COMMENTS AND
TESTIMONY FROM A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
QUESTIONABLE NATURE ABOUT. THE
VALIDITY OF OUR MACHINES- WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
BIPARTISAN TO HOLD
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS I
WELCOMED COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO
WISH TO. PUT OUT THERE AND
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
AND HAVE CONVERSATIONS DIALOGUE
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY THE
PLEASURE THE OPPORTUNITY. THE
LUXURY OF BEING ABLE TO GO AND
TOUR MULTIPLE RESTAURANT VOTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN MY TENURE HERE
AND I'VE YET TO SEE. ANY
EVIDENCE OF VOTER FRAUD. AND
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US TO SPEAK
WITH A SENSE. OF PASSION AND
RECOGNIZING THAT WE ARE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND WE SUPPORT
OUR ELECTIONS INTEGRITY AND SO
AGAIN I SAY THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR A BUNCH OF
RHETORIC BUT I WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
BIPARTISAN FASHION TO HAVE
REGISTRARS INTO DO TOWARDS
HERSELF TO. OPEN UP AND BE AS
TRANSPARENT I'VE SEEN IT I
WELCOME YOU TO PUT IN THE WORK
PUT IN THE WORK AND NOT JUST
EMPTY RHETORIC TO DO SO AND
AGAIN WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
TESTIMONY OF THIS ORGANIZATION
ELECTIONS A TEDDY PROJECT THE
COMPLETE FALSEHOOD FROM
WYOMING. WHY SHOULD WE ALLOW.
ENTITIES FROM WYOMING TELL US
HOW WE SHOULD DO ELECTIONS. IN
WHICH WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
RECORD TURN OUT ALL ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM IT'S GOOD FOR
DEMOCRACY AND THAT'S WHY I FEEL
SO PASSION ABOUT THIS AND WAS
SO EXCITED TO SEE. THE
CONTINUATION OF THIS ESPECIALLY
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER. AND
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE-
SENATOR- BURKE AS WELL AS-
MISTER PERMANENTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING THE FOURTH.
THANK YOU MR LOW. WE'RE GOING
TO BRIEFLY GO BACK- TO PEOPLE
OR TO THE OPERATOR FOR PEOPLE
THAT WE HAD A FEW PEOPLE ON THE
LINE WHO HADN'T BEEN ASSIGNED A
NUMBER YET SO IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE WAS NOBODY. THERE WERE.
FIVE PEOPLE STILL ON THE LINE
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK. MR
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
BACK- PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO WHO ARE ON THE ON
THE LINE AS OF RIGHT NOW.
CERTAINLY ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. OUR FIRST.
IS LINE TWO ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES SIR MY NAME IS
DENISE PORSCHE AND- TO SEE THAT
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF FRAUD.
REGISTER ONLINE FOLKS JUST
REMIND FOLKS PLEASE PROVIDE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU. YOU
LOOK AT THAT AND A MAILING OUT
BALLOTS THAT WERE. THE DAY
SPEAKER. WILL MOVE THE LINE ONE
FIFTY IS GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
FIFTY YOU'RE OPEN. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE THE LINE TWO
ONE TWO TWO TWELVE YEAR OPEN.
HELLO YES GOOD MORNING YES WE
CAN BUT NOT OKAY- I NAME A
SPROCKET DOT I'M A REGISTERED
VOTER IN CINEMA COUNTY NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU IT'S- IT UP BORROWED ARE
PROUD THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS BACK
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY I
STRONGLY ON BOARD AND BE TWENTY
NINE SEEMS VERY NORMAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE RESIDENCY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT. NEXT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE ONE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING TO THE
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO HELLO HELLO. CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY SORRY
I'M THIS IS ALL NEW TO ME NO
PROBLEM- FIRST OF ALL I'M NOT
UNDERSTANDING WHY THESE FOLKS
AREN'T ABLE TO. VOICE THEIR
OPINION SO THE OTHER MEDIA.
PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND YOUR WE
HAD WE HAD PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
A PROPOSITION AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL FOR THREE MINUTES EACH AND
THEN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES GET
TO PROVIDE THEIR NAME THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND THEIR
ORGANIZATION THERE WITH IF ANY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND DO THAT. MY
NAME IS KATHY STEAM BURKE I AM
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA READING.
I AM WITH OPEN SHASTA COALITION
AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO
SB TWENTY NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YES WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MANY RESTORED YOU'RE
RIGHT AND I'M A SOLANO COUNTY
SENT- REPUBLICAN CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SB TWENTY NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE LINE TWO
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS BRENDA BRANDY
FIFTEEN AND I OPPOSE SB TWO TWO
NINE THANK YOU FOR INDIVIDUALS
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE ELEVEN- I HAD. M.
ELECTIONS THAT COULD BE PROGRAM
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AT THREE TWENTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THAT'S ONE TO LINE ONE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE ONE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE. WHAT ARE YOU DOING.
HI WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT IN
THE ELECTION COMMITTEE. WILL
MOVE ON I GUESS TO THE NEXT
WHICH IS ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE OH NINE. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES AGAIN. HI MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE PLAY A LOT
AND I FIRMLY OPPOSE SB TWENTY
NINE. SO EASY TO GET DEATH ROW
SINCE AND HAVE A CANNOT THANK
YOUNG- BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS MELISSA TAPE NUMBER BECAME A
COUNTY ACTUALLY OPPOSED SB
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
SIXTY THREE. ONE SIXTY THREE
YES YOU EUROPE. I KEEP CALLING
BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT TO SAY AND
YOU SHOULD NOT BE CUTTING OFF
CALIFORNIA'S. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. NEXT WE'RE GOING THE
LINE BETWEEN TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHECK TWENTY. YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS A
POPULATION AND WITH L. A.
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE TWO THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN- YES GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ALKA METRO I'M A
REGISTERED VOTER FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WITH ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE- TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT ELECTORAL
POLITICS MY COLLEAGUES THERE IS
CONFUSION AS TO HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE SO ON THE LINE- BUT- I'D
LIKE TO THINK THE OPERATOR FOR
DOING A GREAT JOB. THANK YOU
THE NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE YES
THIS STUDY INTENT FROM THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY CALIFORNIA I
AM A STRONGLY AGAINST THE S. B.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY
FIVE YEAR OPEN. YES I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MINE IS
RECORDED CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS LAURA
SMITH I'M A CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR TWENTY POINT TWO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU FOR CALLING AGAIN WE
GOT TO LAST TIME AS WELL.
BOCHOLT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
MOVE TO THE LINE TWO THIRTY
THREE BUT- HELLO YES MY NAME IS
ANDREA WYLER I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB TWENTY NINE THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH EVERYONE
THAT IS GREAT SO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT IS CUT OFF MOVING BACK
TO ANY COLLEAGUES THAT WANT TO
MAKE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS ON
THE BILL SEEING NONE- CENTER
AMBERG. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I WOULD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. OF I CAN
INTEGRITY IS A PERSONAL ISSUE
WITH ME- SOME. THIRTY PLUS
YEARS AGO ALL IN ORANGE COUNTY.
ONE GROUP POSTED PEOPLE DRESSED
AS POLICE OFFICERS WITH SIZES
THAT NONCITIZENS MAY NOT VOTE.
FOR THE OSTENSIBLE PURPOSE OF.
EVENTING LATINOS FROM VOTE-
THAT WAS AN OUTRAGE THERE WAS A
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION I WAS IN
THE WEST IS OFFICE THE TIME AND
I RAN AGAINST THE PERSON WHO
BENEFITTED FROM THAT ACTIVITY-
AND ACTUALLY ONE. IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND SO WHEN I CAME TO
THE ASSEMBLY BOTH TIMES THE
SECOND TIME FIFTEEN YEARS AGO I
CHAIR THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
AND AT THAT POINT THE ISSUES OF
ELECTION FRAUD WERE BEING
RAISED AND I ASKED IMPLORED BY
ASKING EMPLOYER AGAIN TODAY
THAT IF YOU NOW ALL OF A
VIOLATION OF THE LAW YOU SHOULD
REPORT IT USUALLY REPORTED THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SURE REPORT
YOUR LOCAL POLICE- YOUR YOUR
YOUR LOCAL POLICE YOU SHOULD
REPORT IT TO THE U. S. ATTORNEY.
WE'RE ALL CONCERNED ABOUT
ELECTION INTEGRITY- THOSE
REPORTS HAVE NOT BEEN REALLY
FORTHCOMING. THERE BEEN SOME
INVESTIGATIONS BUT REALLY.
THERE'S NO. SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE OF VOTER FRAUD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I AGREE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SARTELL THAT
CONFIDENCE IN OUR ELECTION IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO A
DEMOCRACY HOWEVER
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION ABOUT THIS
ELECTION IN PARTICULAR. HAS
BEEN DANGEROUS WE SAW WHEN
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION WITH
DISSEMINATED FROM THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF WHAT HAPPENS WHAT
HAPPENS IS WHEN PEOPLE LOSE
FAITH IN THE THIRTY ELECTION.
THEY RESORT TO EXTRAORDINARY
MEANS THEN TO ASSERT THEIR WILL
OVER RUNNING THE CAPITAL. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT ACCURATE
INFORMATION BE DISSEMINATED
ABOUT OUR ELECTION PROCESS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA CONTRARY TO
WHAT SOME OF THE FOLKS ON THE
PHONE HAD TO SAY WE HAVE AN
EXTRAORDINARY ELECTION AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THAT FOLKS
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS FRAUD TO
THE EXTENT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
LISTENING BELIEVES WHAT. THEY
SHOULD CONTACT THE FOR
REPUBLICANS THAT BEAT THE FOUR
DEMOCRATS WHO WERE IN OFFICE
AND LET THEM KNOW NO DOUBT THE
RESIGNED AT THAT POINT ONCE
THEY FIND OUT ABOUT THIS ISSUE
I'M BEING A BIT SARCASTIC. BUT
IT IS TRUE THAT IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THIS
WAS ELECTION WHERE ACCORDING TO
BILL BARR. THE FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL ACCORDING TO MITCH
MCCONNELL. THIS ELECTION WAS
RUN WITH INTEGRITY AND SO. BY
EXTENDING THE PROTECTIONS OF
THE PROVISIONS OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION HERE WHEN WE
ARE STILL IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC. DESKS ARE AT THEIR
HIGHEST. CASES ARE EXTREMELY
HIGH. THE INCIDENCE OF
TRANSMISSION IS STILL EXTREMELY
HIGH IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
PASSED THIS MEASURE SO I URGE A
NO VOTE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU US SENATOR AND- YOU
YOU YOU RIGHTFULLY USE THE
TERMS OF MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION WE HAD A CALL
USE THE TERM RHETORIC THAT'S
ALL ACCURATE- BUT I WANT TO BE
MORE BLUNT. WILL HAVE LOST
FAITH IN OUR ELECTION SYSTEM
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN LIED TO.
THEY'VE BEEN LIED TO BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THEY'VE BEEN LIED TO BY FEDERAL
AND STATE ELECTED OFFICIALS
INCLUDING. ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
THIS BUILDING NOT AT THIS DAIS.
BUT IN THIS BUILDING- AND THEY
HAVE BEEN LIGHT AND IN THIS
LINE. THAT IS HAPPENED OVER AND
OVER AGAIN AROUND THE INTEGRITY
OF THE ELECTION IN TWENTY
TWENTY. HAS DIRECTLY UNDERMINE
OUR DEMOCRACY- AND IT DIRECTLY
LED TO THE ATTACK ON THE
CAPITAL ON JANUARY SIXTH- AND
IT YEAH I SEE IN OTHER STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THAT THE
ARSONISTS THE LIARS. ARE NOW
CLAIMING THAT THEY HAVE THE
SOLUTION. TO THE FIRE THAT'S
RAGING TO THE DISINFORMATION IN
THE DISTRUST THAT EXISTS. BY
CLAMPING DOWN AND PASSING VOTER
SUPPRESSION LAWS- AND THAT IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAD A- REMARKABLY
TRANSPARENT OPEN SUCCESSFUL
ELECTION. IN TWENTY TWENTY. WE
HAD SOME OF THE HIGHEST TURNOUT
IN GENERATIONS. THAT WE'VE HAD
IN CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE A LOT
OF. ACCUSATIONS THAT ARE BEING
THROWN AROUND WITH ZERO
EVIDENCE- AS THE SENDER SAID SO
IF YOU HAVE EVIDENCE. PROVIDE
YOUR EVIDENCE SOME THINGS THAT
WERE SAID CALIFORNIA'S VOTER
ROLLS ARE NOT CLEAN ARE
ACCURATE. INTERMENT ARE AND ARE
NOT MAINTAINING COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL LAW THIS IS FALSE. WITH
MORE THAN TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE
ON THE VOTER ROLLS STATEWIDE
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
SMALL NUMBER OF RECORDS. THAT
HAVE NOT YET BEEN UPDATED TO
REFLECT RECENT DEATHS AND
CHANGES IN VOTER ADDRESSES.
THERE ARE MEASURES IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA TO UPDATE VOTER
LISTS. AS REQUIRED BY STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW IN A SAFETY GUARD
AGAINST FRAUD. CALIFORNIA GETS
DEATH RECORDS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. ON
A WEEKLY BASIS WE GET FELONY
RECORDS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ON A MONTHLY BASIS. AND WE GET
CHANGE OF ADDRESS INFORMATION
FROM THE DMV ON A DAILY BASIS.
AND RUN THOSE AGAINST THE
STATEWIDE VOTER REGISTRATION
DATABASE. THE STATE ALSO GETS
NATIONAL CHANGE OF ADDRESS
INFORMATION. TO CHECK FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MOVED OUT OF
STATE. NO I ALREADY SPOKE TO
THE ACCUSATIONS OF WIDESPREAD
FRAUD IN TWENTY TWENTY THAT
SIMPLY DON'T EXIST- AND
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT IT
CLAIMS THAT THEY FOUND MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND REGISTERED. CALIFORNIA
VOTERS WHO HAVE LIKELY DIED OR
MOVED POLITIFACT LOOKED AT THIS
CLAIM AND FOUND THAT ELECTION
EXPERTS WERE HIGHLY SKEPTICAL.
OF THE GROUP'S FIGURE INSTEAD
OF THE MENORES MEASURES USED TO
UPDATE VOTER ROLLS WHICH I
SPOKE TO A MINUTE AGO. AND THE
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO PREVENT
FRAUD. SO I GET VERY FRUSTRATED
BY PEOPLE. THAT THAT THROW
AROUND BASELESS ACCUSATIONS
THAT UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY
AND LET'S BE CLEAR THAT THAT IS
WHAT. THESE PEOPLE ARE DOING.
SO I APPRECIATE THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING YOUR BILL TODAY. IT'S
BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK WITH
YOU OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. ON ELECTIONS ISSUES- I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE IN A NEW ROLE- OVER IN
THE SENATE- AND IT. STRONGLY
RECOMMEND IT AND I VOTE FOR
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BERMAN. HI BERMAN HI SAY
ARTURO. NO SE ARTO NO SENATE.
SENATE HI LOW LOW HI MAYES
MAYES HI MULLIN HI MULLIN HI
RUBIO RUBIO HI. AT SIX TO ONE
THANK YOU THAT BILL PASSES ON A
SIX TO ONE VOTE. THANK YOU AND
THE MEETING IS ADJOURNED.